[Musique]
légende veut que paris souhaite une des
plus belles villes du monde
disons bien vite que pour ne pas
contredire cette belle légende il y a
beaucoup pas entreprendre et vite
en survolant le centre de paris on
s'aperçoit immédiatement de
l'enchevêtrement des toits et des rues
l'air et le soleil pénètre mal dans la
ville et s'en est sans soleil
une ville dont malades regardez les murs
ne respire plus une sorte de lèpre les
ronge et un jour de tout cela il ne
restera que de la poussière cette
poussière qui est partout dans le centre
de paris cette poussière que les poumons
à leur tour reut soir il faut avoir peu
d'estimé pour ceux qui confondent
pittoresque et audi
pour ceux qui préfèrent les mazures
coulante au bien-être des hommes
[Musique]
le coeur de paris est malade mais c'est
là pourtant qu'on entasse ce qui doit
leur servir et de nouveau la poussière
l'inévitable poussière retombe sur la
nourriture du lendemain le steak pommes
frites est peut être le meilleur du
monde à paris mais la viande parfois
traîne à terre dans ce labyrinthe peu un
peu plus rien ne circule
ni le soleil ni l'air ni même les hommes
l'encombrement devient le signe de paris
les carrefours et les rues sont des
terrains où la voiture chasse de piétons
[Musique]
quittons le centre pour atteindre la
banlieue qui voyons nous exactement
contraire des zones immenses de terrains
inutilisés
on se demande bien pourquoi d'autant
qu'en certains endroits le chemin de fer
passes inutiles pour ceux qui n'habitent
pas là
[Musique]
pour d'autres lieux cet esprit
d'invention et d'originalité qui
paraît-il nous caractérise nous autres
français donnent les résultats que voici
des maisons minuscule sans confort mais
que le propriétaire a voulu différente
de la voisine et cela s'appelle sam
suffit ainsi de cabane en cabane la
banlieue s'étire trice offrant à celui
qui rentre de paris après le travail
le spectacle gris qui est comme un
purgatoire immérité usine le jour rue
sans fleurs et sans verdure le soir
d'autres fois au paysage s'ajoutent
encore la cheminée qui crache ses
poussières et la suie sur la tête des
enfants
[Musique]
et chaque matin l'homme repart il marche
vers la gare lointaine lourdes ça
fatigue de la veille qui déjà cinq fois
nous avons vu maintenant quelques-unes
des imperfections de paris avant
d'aborder la solution ou les solutions
il convient de bien connaître le
problème est avant tout le sous sol
car évidemment avant de construire
encore faut-il savoir sur quoi on
construit si nous sommes aujourd'hui
place de l'alma c'est que nous y avons
l'occasion de voir justement ce sous sol
qui est comme éventrées et nous voyons
aussi ce qu'on peut faire dans ce
sous-sol exactement des travaux très
importants
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi nous avons donné rendez
vous ici à monsieur étudiants qui est
architecte et qui depuis très longtemps
depuis des années étudie ce problème du
sous sol parisien
monsieur études genre pourriez vous nous
expliquer rapidement depuis combien de
temps se livrent à des études du sous
sol pour l'urbanisme
depuis 1933 est ce que j'avais déjà des
résultats très intéressants pour
l'ensemble une seule paris est arrivé à
faire des études préliminaires assez
poussée mais il y en a moins eu lieu à
l'est
miser et à les mettre 3 selon les cas
d'espèce sur place selon chaque cas
particulier qui peut se présente
est ce qu'il existe des documents sur
cette question oui qu'il est ce premier
document monsieur tube joe ce premier
document montre en arracher une coupe
géologique dans la constitution du sous
sol parisien
comme vous le savez le sous-sol de paris
se prête admirablement aux travaux de
réalisation souterraine et il est
essentiellement constituée par des
évolutions de grammes de marne baird de
marne sucrage ips de marne de hot chips
de gypse de calcaire grossier c'est
andrew au bout d'un très dur comme celui
de new york c'est à ce seul tendre
surtout s'ils ont atteint la couche de
cale pieds de créer qui se trouve à n
avoir une épaisseur de 300 mètres sous
paris mais en fait c'est montmartre
qu'on voit la préfète hamouma la coupe
et fait un beau match et vous avez
environ 25 mètres de hauteur dans cette
épaisseur jusqu'au calcaire de
saint-ouen et vous savez qu à montmartre
le gypse a donné beaucoup de mal à la
pour la construction notamment dû
sacrifier les écroulements il y ait deux
grièvement et paul thériault ma il ya eu
un foudroyage général ce qui a
occasionné des fantic considérable qui
donne beaucoup de mal aux architectes
actuellement et puis on a fait toutes
les carrières aussi mauvais qu'on a fait
sauter les carrières fait six mois
qu'ils avaient des bandes ixic a chez
nous il y avait oui il y avait des
malfaiteurs qui avaient fait leur
perdent ce sauna se marre et on a cru
bon à ce moment vers 19 heures quel est
le deuxième document que jamais là
derrière
le deuxième document représente en
arracher de la place de l'opéra
ceci vous donne une idée de ce qu'est la
l'encombrement du sous sol en convenant
du soda l'opéra qui comporte outre le
métropolite r les différentes stations
et voulez vous nous montrez un peu aigri
les lignes et du métropolitain des
stations les intercommunication des sacs
d'intercommunication comme vous lie elle
est également des égouts le réseau des
égouts qui passent là aussi bien
d'ailleurs partout ailleurs où l'on peut
dire c'est à peu près la même chose que
tout paris le bien sur l'eau
l'électricité le gaz téléphone de
telegraaf un encombrement concerne le
comprimé et les chauffage urbain et si
on compare avec les autres capitales
peut-on dire que le l'encombrement du
sol parisien est plus important le pari
est beaucoup plus encombrée en sous sol
que les autres capitales parce que
précisément son sol se prête à ces
réalisations déjà
voulez vous nous montrez l'autre
document s'il vous plaît du troisième
vous avez ici une autre vue de parier
avec l'arraché de la station bir abo qui
traverse la salle mirabeau qui traverse
la seine sous le lit du fleuve et le
métro passe cette fois je crois sous la
selle le métro travers cette fois la
scène et qu'il est ce dernier document
enfin signer les documents représentent
l'avenir projet l'avenir c'est le projet
de voies souterraines qui a été établi
par le gic us le groupe d'études et de
coordination de l'urbanisme souterrain
où nous de nous expliquer rapidement et
qui résout le problème non seulement de
la traversée de paris mais d'adp est
certes puissante par des autoroutes
souterraines en fait tous et où ces
traces et lumineux sont des d'aider les
as et d'autoroutes furent les grandes
autoroutes futur avec le grand problème
de traversée de paris et la traversée
nord-sud qui est résolu
si et la traversée est ouest de cardo et
le decumanus des romains et cela est
repris dans son idée et c'est un
ensemble extrêmement simple est de
tradition purement romaine mais on peut
dire que cet urbanisme souterrain s'il
résout le problème de la circulation ne
résout pas du tout par contre le
problème de l'habitat a bien sûr et là
il ya d'autres visions qui sont
importantes et d'autre solution apporte
yens entendu mais nous ne combattons pas
toutes les solutions d'élévation da il
s'agit d'un réseau d'un problème
particulier qui est celui de la
circulation et on nous résumer donc un
sous sol extrêmement tendre déjà très
encombré mais dans lequel on peut encore
faire beaucoup de choses mais tout de
suite il nous faut plonger dans le temps
car il est un autre conditionnement
celui de l'histoire et j'ai à côté de
moi la personne qui est chargé à l'hôtel
de ville de collectionner les documents
d'urbanisme joueurs qui nous explique
justement ce graphique qui représente
paris au moment du bas-empire au début
du moyen-âge
il faut d'abord rappeler que lutèce est
rentré dans l'histoire un lent 52 avant
jésus-christ lorsque les romains l'ont
occupé après leurs occupations
lutèce a débordé sur la rive gauche et a
formé une vitesse mot romaine magnifique
qui a été supprimée par une invasion
barbare et quels sont les
conditionnements d'urbanisme au
moyen-âge au début du moyen-âge et bien
une fois les rangs mêmes parties
l'avaient année c'est surtout la trace
de leurs voix et sûre selon goal et vous
nous les montrer oui il y avait surtout
la voie principale qui avait été affirmé
par du pavage d'ailleurs la rue
saint-jacques et la rue saint martin qui
est toujours la voie maîtresse de paris
dont on construit donc à ce moment là
des églises un peu partout on les voit
d'ailleurs quelles sont les principales
eh bien les principales c'est d'abord
l'église saint-etienne qui a été
construit sous les romains concilie
notre dame sera construite à son
emplacement ensuite sur la rive gauche
sainte geneviève qui s'appelait les
saints apôtres construite sous clovis et
les saint germain des prés s'appelait
saint vincent sainte croix est en fait à
ce moment là pour nous résumer au
construit autour des églises sans aucun
plan d'ensemble et non ce sont des
maisons qui se juxtaposent et qui forme
les prochains play qui forment les
prochaines burqa menait 4 à paris en se
développant nous trouvons paris à la fin
du moyen-âge exactement sous le règne de
quel droit d philippe auguste dont voit
immédiatement évidemment qu'il ya un
agrandissement considère peut-on dire
que cet agrandissement s'est fait selon
un plan déterminé peut être non mais
c'est fait selon la logique des choses
c'étaient les bateliers qui circulait
sur la selle le long de la seine lara
lez lille est devenue prospère elle a
éclaté sur la rive droite qui était la
plus propice à la navigation et elle a
formé la rive droite commerçante avec
les halles créé par philippe auguste
alors les richesses qui s'y trouve et il
a fallu les protégés de neuf ans que
l'ennemi ce qui a fait que philippe
auguste à créer une enceinte pour les
protéger et on voit apparaître le
premier louvre est en fait de on a
encore les quatre cette fois nous avons
les quatre abbaye les quatre abbayes et
oui les églises ont été reconstruites
parce que tout d'ailleurs
et sur la rive gauche alors saint
germain s'est retrouvé sainte-geneviève
aussi et de nouvelle abbaye apparaissent
alors c'est martin deschamps et l'abbaye
c'est dingue deschamps et n'est-ce pas
aussi l'apparition du quartier étudiant
à 6 et c'est très important quel endroit
et bien d'abord ça a été
et la mort ça a été la bei saint-victor
avec champeau abena et alors la paix
comment dirais-je la cité universitaire
s'est développé autour du petit pont et
elle a gagné toute la montagne sainte
geneviève par la suite
cette carte que nous avons maintenant
sous les yeux vo pour l'époque et qui va
d'henri iv à la révolution française il
suffit d'y regarder pour se rendre
compte que l'accroissement se fait selon
un mode concentriques mais quelle est la
caractéristique de toute cette époque
est la caractéristique final de toute
cette époque c'est la disparition des
enceintes que louis xiv va utiliser pour
former des premiers boulevard en
utilisant l'enceinte de charles 5 et
celle de louis xiii et ses boulevards
seront plantés d'arbres la verdure
apparaît dans paris effectivement
d'ailleurs on voit qu'au centre le vieux
paris n'arrête absolument noir minière
ce manque une tâche de verdure alors
qu'au contraire on doit tout de suite
que à l'est comme à l'ouest
il y avait effectivement des taches
vertes qui apparaissent oui l'expansion
de paris d'ailleurs se fait nettement
vers l'ouest à partir du louvre où
chaque droit pour sa pierre etc colbert
qui amorce la fameuse percée vers
l'ouest et faire la butte de l'arc de
triomphe mais il n'y at il pas aussi
constitution d'une nouvelle enceinte qui
cette fois ne répond plus à un but
défense mais un tout autre but si elle
se fera à la fin de cette époque ce sera
l'ensemble des fermiers généraux qui ne
sera en fait qu'une enceinte douanières
donc pour nous résumer un urbanisme
cette fois qui n'est pas encore un
urbanisme d'habitat demi en urbanisme
circulation mais qui déjà pense à
l'embellissement de la capitale cet
examen
nous en arrivons maintenant au monde
moderne les chemins de fer existe
napoléon iii prend la suite de napoléon
1er est déjà des problèmes de
circulation se pose très proches de ceux
aujourd'hui comment la faire haussmann
et bien haussmann va vouloir réaliser de
grandes liaisons
il double la grande croisée de paris en
créant le boulevard de strasbourg de
sébastopol et le boulevard saint-michel
autour des grands carrefours
il fait des départs de voir qui relie
entre elles les gars qui sont déjà
amorcés évidemment elles sont bien plus
petit que maintenant il n'y aurait pas
beaucoup le nom peut-être pas et il veut
surtout je crois en même temps que des
problèmes de circulation résoudre du
côté de l'est
un problème de sécurité juin 48 au bout
de ces grandes voies y pose des casernes
qui sont destinés à prendre à revers une
une émeute éventuelle mais ce qu'il n'ya
pas aussi un urbanisme d'embellissement
chez napoléon iii surtout fait le côté
grandeur de naples endroit lorsqu'il
disait je veux faire de paris la plus
belle ville du monde
si napoléon iii avait vécu à londres et
il était influencée par l'urbanisme
anglais et il a créé toute une série de
grands parc montsouris les buttes
chaumont le parc de montceau et il a
ménagé les bois de boulogne et le bois
de vincennes et osman n'a pas voulu
qu'on lui fasse le reproche de ne pas
penser à l'embellissement de paris
puisque en général il essayait de mettre
au bout de ces grandes percées un
monument en l'espèce la fontaine de
saint michel au bout de sébastopol de
cinq boucles parvis de notre-dame le
parvis de notre-dame reset nsn
glissement mais qui est très
controversée en fait il a fait
disparaître tout le vieux paris de la
cité qui est pourtant le coeur de paris
qui méritait peut-être d'être respecté
donc pour nous résumer on peut dire
kossmann et napoléon iii car en fait ils
sont très proches l'un de l'autre sont
les premiers à penser le problème de
paris dans son ensemble sur le plan de
l'urbanisme de circulation un urbanisme
d'embellissement et un urbanisme
d'habitat quand il ya des lotissements
qui sont très importants sont les
premiers qui seront à ce moment là puis
thil à vue d'ensemble
oui ils ont voulu faire certainement un
plan d'un ménage le plan général
d'aménagement de paris il vaut ce qu'il
vaut mais il a été
le sous sol l'histoire cela peut vous
paraître terriblement abstrait mais dans
ces maisons délabrées de paris des gens
vivent et il appartient aux sociologues
d'étudier leur comportement du chambard
et je m'excuse nous intéresse mais vous
êtes sociologue et j'aimerais que vous
nous expliquiez simplement et rapidement
ce que la sociologie peu de nos jours à
porter à l'urbanisme bien elle peut
servir à l'urbaniste bien des manières
elle peut faire connaître comment dans
une ville comme paris le logement toutes
les conditions de vie peuvent avoir une
influence sur le comportement des hommes
de toutes les couches de la population
elle peut faire comprendre surtout je
crois que c'est ça l'essentiel
quels sont leurs besoins réels quelles
sont leurs aspirations essayer de les
faire participer à au plan d'urbanisme
qu'on fait pour eux que l'urbanisme ne
soit pas un travail qui se fait en
chambre mais qui partent des besoins
observer sur le terrain
qu'il s'agisse de gens de catégorie
extrêmement différente que tout le monde
puisse être touchés par des études de ce
genre pour que tout le monde puisse y
participer et que l'urban et sur la
chose de tout le monde voilà je crois un
des points essentiels et aujourd'hui
vous êtes venus ici justement pour vous
livrer une enquête particulier et bien
nous faisons un travail dans ce secteur
du xiiie arrondissement qui est très
défavorisé et dans lequel il y à
vraiment des logements très difficile
nous faisons tantôt d'ailleurs des
études dans ces logements très mauvais
d'eau dans des logements nouveaux ça
dépend des moments
et aujourd'hui il s'agit vraiment d'une
enquête dans des conditions essentielles
mais volontiers écouter génie est ce que
vous pourriez aller chercher faisait lui
simplement deux ou trois questions ne
peut pas faire tout l'anc est
naturellement
devant tout le monde c'est très longue
laissons vous ne riez pas aussi par
hasard des documents pouvant justement
illustrer votre votre théorie au
certainement certainement j'en ai dans
cette serviette
quel est ce premier document eh bien
c'est la délinquance juvénile à paris
vous voyez qu'elle est beaucoup plus
forte dans la partie est de paris elle
existe aussi dans la partie ouest mais
d'une façon différente
ce n'est pas le même genre de
délinquance il faut lui dire de côté et
bien dans la partie est de paris que
vous voyez ici représentée par les
points les zones noires et zone oi vous
voyez un genre de délinquance qui est
très lié aux milieux d'habitat à
l'existence de bandes d'enfants dans les
impasses sur les hbpm etc dans l'autre
partie de paris c'est une délinquance
tout à fait différente qui est une
délinquance y ait un milieu aisé
quel est le deuxième document voilà
alors que l'âge moyen des immeubles à
paris voyez ce centre de paris qui est
très défavorisés dans le xiiie
arrondissement où nous nous trouvons ce
n'est pas l'habit talent plus anciens
c'est un habitat qui est pas très ancien
mais qui est déjà extrêmement vétustes
et mal mal entretenues julien
probablement que les matériaux l'origine
n'était pas bon non certainement et puis
il ya une question d'aménagement du
terrain il faut tout changer
actuellement voilà alors le nombre
d'habitants par pièce dans paris vous
voyez toujours cette même figure de
l'est de paris puis à dire que l'est est
en deuil
le l'estrie elle doit paraître et noir
et c'est effectivement une figure très
décevante de voir qu'il y à beaucoup
plus d'habitants par pièce dans ce
domaine qui a une densité d'occupation
des logements très forte ce qui a une
influence sur le développement de
maladies telles que la tuberculose
là aussi on voit que le poids et la
taille déconstruite 20 ans de ce côté de
paris est plus faible que du côté ouest
plus favorisés du côté ouest où on voit
dans le xvième dans le viiième dans le 7
17e ou 7e arrondissement des quartiers
beaucoup plus aisés donc
indiscutablement l'habitat une influence
c'est même d'un point de vue
sociologique vous arrivé à la conclusion
que l'habitat une influence énorme sur
les gentils amis l'habitat une influence
énorme sur les gens et d'un autre côté
les gens d'un certain niveau de vie ne
peuvent aller que du côté où les
logements sont moins chères parce qu'ils
sont moins bon donc
il ya une canalisation des gens d'un
certain milieu social d'un certain
revenu d'une certaine classe sociale du
même côté de paris tandis que les autres
restent dans un secteur même si autre
assistante qui revient que la locataire
de l'endroit
[Musique]
nous allons commencer à poser quelques
questions parmi beaucoup d'autres à
madame robert madame mis à part dont
madame rémy lyon madame rémy
pourriez-vous nous dire par exemple
quelles sont les principales difficultés
que vous rencontrez dans votre logement
pourquoi vous savez monsieur les
principales difficultés je trouve dans
mon logement
c'est que c'est un logement qu'il n'y a
ni eau ni gaz ni électricité ni vater et
nous avons très loin aller chercher
l'eau et la descendre et la montée
vraiment c'est pénible
les enfants vous savez la place qu'on
peut réserver aux enfants c'est que dans
une pièce dispose cinq lits et ya une
toute petite en faire juste pour
l'élever les mets deux bouts et les
admire la cuisine les faire manger deux
fois qu'on ne peut pas mettre la table
en une seule fois une seule fois ils
sont nombreux qui attendent
mais au juste que peuvent-ils espérer
pour le savoir changeons de quartier du
pont puis nous sommes venus chez vous
pour vous demander
et s'il existe selon vous une solution
d'urbanisme pour pari foot annuler les
effets d'une langue négligence et
chercher tous les moyens par lesquels
paris peut redevenir une ville de beauté
et d'harmonie
voudriez voir à la gentillesse de nous
montrer quelques exemples oui aux
lentilles je vais expliquer je peux vous
expliquer que certains des moyens par
lesquels on peut atteindre le but
d'ailleurs je crois monsieur qobuz est
qu'il ya très longtemps que vous
réfléchissez à ces problèmes d'urbanisme
trentaine d'années est ce que vous êtes
arrivé tout de suite au plan définitif
ou bien au contraire vous avez eu des
étapes successives
j'ai cherché très longtemps et j'ai créé
des blancs successifs
j'ai eu l'occasion de les montrer
parfois dans des expositions de les
exposer dans des livres mais petit à
petit le silence s'étend sur ces choses
on n'a jamais répondu à ses plans
non non par des quolibets parfois ou ou
me tenais mais l'opinion est saisi par
diverses manifestations très nette qui
ont eu lieu en particulier celle du
pavillon des temps nouveaux
en 1937 à l'expression 37 et cela va les
réunir en un livre s'il s' il
précisément
le directeur des éditions de minuit il
m'a demandé l'autre jour on m'a dit nous
allons publier mes peurs le cow boys et
de paris de 55 1922
c'est à dire oui et 33 ans de plans dans
un gros livre fait dans 9 7 qui
reproduira de l'été sceller l est il
blanc qui ont déjà été publiés qui sont
parus qui ont été soumises a loupé l
opinion ne peut être inattentif et tout
le tout rassembler en une seule heure en
un seul exemplaire en un seul volume
le gros volume important est ce que vous
auriez l'obligeant de faire quelques
dessins pour nous montrer justement les
étapes de cette théorie oui sa volonté
je peux vous expliquer en quelques
instants
il faut que je prenne mon peuple et je
vais vous montrer comment paris est né
sur un fleuve elle a croisé de sa route
la première ville fut dans des
dimensions normales puis sa crue tant
ceinture considérable successives
jusqu'au roi et contenant tout de même
une masse de population déjà très forte
provoquant au temps de louis xiv et
louis 15 en affolement déjà au moment où
les premiers carrosse apparurent est la
ville et on disait c'est une ville où
les hommes ce match les uns sur les
autres
mais subitement au machiniste c'est à
dire un siècle après 2
le désastre devient totale car
l'industrie se développe autour de la
ville en créant des sites industriels
puis les cités ouvrières se tenir autour
des styles des secteurs industriels de
banlieue et ainsi de suite par ceinture
successives la ville fini par devenir
tentaculaire atteignant un diamètre de
50 80 km ou davantage ou 100 km e et
rendant ainsi les transports absolument
le transport des transports les rendant
absolument impossible inefficace et
jetant sur les hommes un malaise à
trotski devenu maintenant catastrophique
est votre solution avoue d'aboutir
al'inverse ma solution c'est de
reprendre le problème à froid de
regarder comment sont les choses où sont
les événements mettre de l'ordre dans
quelque sorte et d'obtenir par balles et
un examen doctrinal suffisamment sain
est vrai mais ce mois d'obtenir la
remise en ordre de paris et le sol et
vous nous montrez le dessin un spectacle
d'un pari tout à fait possibles tels que
par exemple celui ci de vie montre le
pari possible dans paris rentré chez lui
hier à paris mais ça ça oblige à les
destruction au ce plan dont toute la vie
n'est faite que de destruction et de
reconstruction et particulièrement la
vie des villes
voulez vous nous montrez ce qui seraient
détruits sur ce dessin juste sur ce
dessin le centre qui est déjà le qui est
constamment qui s'est constamment refait
depuis la période romaine période
moyenâgeuse après des princes et rois et
des
des républiques tout ce centre qui se
refait sur lui-même comme tout à fait un
phénomène naturel peut redonner une
vitalité incroyable à paris grâce aux
techniques modernes qui offrent le
chemin la solution le pont pour passer
du neuf ont salué ces cubes qu'on voit
sur ce dessin au milieu de ce dessin ce
sont en fait les livres les grandes
maisons en fait ce ne sont pas des cubes
en profitant des techniques modernes
vous pouvez bâtir en hauteur et obtenir
par exemple tel qu'il est prévu ici une
cité d'affaires formé de quatre grands
édifices
c'est suffisant de 200 mètres de hauteur
espacées de 400 mètres les uns des
autres occupants de 5% de la surface
seulement les cendres entre 95% et son
pied de surfaces libres des parcs et 1
continue de 400 m plus 400 m plus 400 m
ça fait trois fois 4,12 ça fait 200 m 2
le parc est à dire une immense distance
où tous les problèmes de circulation de
trafic notamment décidé d'abolir voulait
situés ou dans le parisien les
d'affaires bien se mettre là où le mal
est le plus fort et le plus intenable en
ce moment c'est où sont les taudis qui
sont actuellement derrière la porte
saint denis elle apporte
porte-saint-martin mais dites moi
monsieur le corbusier avec ce système
est ce que vous n'allez pas justement
complètement détruire le paris
historique
un nom surtout pas ça ça de moi j'aime
paris
je suis venu passer ma vie entière
depuis 50 ans et j'aime paris et peu
tout ça aboutit qu'ici organiquement
organisée le long de la seine et dans
des lieux qui sont pertinemment dessinée
est limité tout le passé paris se trouve
en sur la rive gauche est sur la rive
droite avec une évasion sur les
champs-elysées et au delà de sade ou
nord de paris comme au sud de paris
il n'y a que 1 développement il s'est
fait soit sous napoléon iii soit sous
les temps l'époque actuelle
quand une partie est un taudis ne faut
pas avoir de remords de l'enlever les
salles grâce aux hôtels n'ont qu'à y
rester saïd mcad marais mais supposons
fait cette transformation selon selon
votre planque et serait la conséquence
pratique de cette transformation par
rapport à l'europe
et bien cette transformation nécessite
je voulais dit la prise en considération
des trois établissements humains et
trois établissements humains
agricoles industriels et des changes
commerçants et l'idée n'est ce pas
nécessite occupent des places
spécifiques sur le territoire des places
fatidique hollande et halberg que je
sais les talwegs les avec ce sont les
valets d'écoulement des eaux
d'écoulement des zones d'écoulement b
d'evans et ce sont ce sont des choses
absolument fatal qui occupent depuis la
préhistoire qui constitue la préhistoire
des cheminements les hommes enfin on
appelle ça les grandes routes du monde
la considération la prise en
considération des trois établissements
humains retrouves c'est avec et la 4e
route d'avion vin vient les rejoindre
tout naturellement car les avions
viennent là où il ya de l'activité
on peut donc lire en conclusion qu'avec
votre transformation paris deviendra en
quelque sorte l'oeil de l'europe
le charme de paris il est évident bien
sûr mais que les images heureuses qui
vont suivre ne servent pas à nous
rassurer à nous faire croire que tout va
bien et que rien ne menace
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
à
oh
charme du paris d'autrefois certes mais
qui devrait donner le désir de voir
s'édifier un pari moderne digne et
respectueux des maisons et des quartiers
anciens
un pari moderne qui résoudrait les
terribles problèmes de l'habitat et de
la circulation et qui serait du même
coup le cadeau de notre époque à celles
qui viendront
charmes de paris tout au long de la
seine et maintenant que nous savons un
peu mieux que l'urbanisme n'est pas
seulement un problème d'architectes mais
que des familles attendent d'ailleurs le
vrai problème le vrai besoin n'omettons
pas il faut que les parisiens
s'intéressent à leur ville le vrai
problème
il est dans un article de monsieur
raymond lopez un autre urbanistes voici
quelque part faisant une comparaison ils
se demandent quand les parisiens se
promèneront il comme l'ont fait certains
anglais avec des banderoles au dessus de
leurs têtes où il est écrit nous voulons
un plan pour notre ville
[Musique]